we can say a few things that are
absolutely Fair one it is not a
conspiracy it's actually a fact it is
historical record us intelligence
agencies were in direct communication
with all of the big tech companies
running social media to manipulate and
control speech there this was directly
related to the hunter Biden laptop
interfering with elections that's how
extreme it was I was personally targeted
by the government and uh leftist Str uh
uh tactics with the um what is it was it
the EIC was it or was it EIP election it
was EIP right election Integrity
partnership or something where they
tried getting people banned and taking
things down and they did successfully do
this government colluding with um
researchers they call them researchers
this is how they can launder government
censorship we know for a fact they're
doing it okay then Elon Musk says he's
going to buy X and he's and he's going
to you know there's talk of restoring
all these accounts bringing people back
and uh oh deep State's going to get
exposed intelligence agencies did get
exposed at the exact same time this is
going down Mark Zuckerberg announces
threads